here we are in the middle of nottingham
and this
wonderful building over here is the mill
of where george green did some work so
this is greens mill and it's still
functioning it was operating yesterday
so if you follow up brady we'll go and
see what this wonderful building is
ah hello graham let us in let us in this
is graham armitage he's the the guy in
charge of the mill
there are several floors brady i hope
you're not filming my backside shall we
go right to the top
this is gonna
give me a heart attack what i do for
science
okay this is the
top floor of the mill there is a cap
underneath with all the works of the
windmill
but this is the room where george green
to get away from his family maybe did
all his mathematical work in this
particular floor and lit by the light
coming in through these small windows
and the work he did in 1820s
up to 1828
revolutionized people's understanding of
physics or it would have done
if only he'd got a broad publication
because some of the stuff he came up
with has been used subsequently by all
theoretical physicists
and has been the basis of quantum field
theory so his work was
120 years ahead of its time in that
sense well um he had very little
education
and he loved mathematics he was
extremely bright he had a relationship
with the mill manager's daughter the
mill manager smith daughter was called
jane and they they had a good time
together having seven children but
because george green wanted to study at
cambridge eventually
i think he wanted to remain a bachelor
all his life because in those days a
bachelor's degree was given to students
who were bachelors they were meant to
progress through there into the church
and so he remained a bachelor all his
life i imagine if it were me
and there were seven children downstairs
i wanted to get as far away as possible
and maybe that's why he came up here all
the time but i'm i'm aligning him he was
he was faithful to jane all the time and
he went to cambridge and got a degree
unfortunately
his education was so poor that when it
came to the maths exam even though he
was the most brilliant mathematician in
the country he came forth which really
annoyed him a lot and the reason was
he was no not very proficient in latin
and greek so maybe if he'd be better at
those you would have heard of him now i
think i ought to show you what a greens
function is so i've got a demonstration
two floors down
oh
this this is the second floor of the
windmill and i've arranged a small
demonstration with the slinky
which is one of those toys that you put
on some stairs and they go down the
stairs it's most kids love them and i've
set it up so that you can see waves on
here so if i bash it at the end here you
can see a wave going along hitting the
end and bouncing back
now then green's idea
was that you could
get a clock and measure the time after
you give an impulse so you could give an
impulse at one position here
say there and look at
the displacement over here at a later
time
so you would bash it here and then you
could with your camera film it and see
how it moves later on so any system
where you can give it a little nudge a
little impulse a little ping like that
anything like that this thing is an
impulse
and you measure the response and you get
a linear response that is governed by
green's function
now that idea entered quantum field
theory because people said let's suppose
we've got an electron here
what's the probability of finding an
electron or some other particle at a
different point at a later time so you
start off with a wave function because
that's the language of field theory
quantum mechanics and you estimate the
probability amplitude is called
elsewhere and to do that you use green's
function you hit it here or create a
particle you measure it there or you
calculate it there and that's what
feynman use that's what schwinger use
that's what all the other people who got
the nobel prize for physics used to
calculate all this stuff and invent this
new field theory
using mathematics that green had
invented more than 120 years earlier
it's more of a technique rather than i
mean each problem has its own greens
function particular to this problem if i
could do this without friction i get a
different response but because it rubs
on the table there's some friction or it
might be heat response for system
elsewhere so the mathematical technique
he invented is widespread throughout
physics so schwinger and dyson came over
in 1993 200 years after the birth of
george greene to honor him and schwinger
who got the nobel prize called his
his speech that he made the greening of
physics george and i
and timothy dyson gave a talk most
wonderful talk i've ever heard about
effective george green on the physics of
the 1940s
albert einstein came over to nottingham
in 1930 to visit his friend bros and
give a talk and he was due to come here
to actually see the windmill and he
arranged to be dropped off here but
there was some delay in the train or
something like that british rail wasn't
that wonderful even then and so he
didn't actually make a trip to it but he
did say
that he thought that george green was uh
10 years ahead of his time in terms of
his mathematics and physics and he
really regarded him highly so though
green according to einstein was a major
player
he died before anybody took any notice
of him so he wrote this fantastic book
and then went to cambridge
and it was william thompson later lord
kelvin who went as a student there after
green had died and what found a copy of
the always lent a copy of his book by
his tutor and he he read it and realized
it was the foundations of the next
generation of physics and so it was lord
kelvin who proselytized it who spoke
well of him and made him famous amongst
the students that came after but green
never had any recognition in his
lifetime
oh there was a memorial service in 1993
in westminster abbey and there's the
tomb of of newton who's regarded as the
founding father of british physics but
alongside that there's uh clark maxwell
kelvin and so on and
in 1993 a memorial plaque was put to
george green with the symbol of a
windmill apparently and and he's up
there in the pantheon of the top british
physicist of all time they had a
windmill on the plaque because nobody
knows what he looked like he he
his daughter was
made had an interview before her death
and so in some sense there's a verbal
history of him but cameras weren't
around there he wasn't famous nobody
painted his portrait and so there's
nothing left
particularly that shows what he looked
like i imagine he's a dusty miller but i
have no idea